[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone salcon here i think we're
about to enter what will be considered
the golden age of biology where not only
do we understand or are starting to
understand the genetic basis of things
but we also have the power to control it
and if you're controlling it then the
creativity gets to a whole other level
so in the decades to come creativity and
biology and also other areas of stem
like mathematics and computing are all
going to converge to really transform
humanity as we know it
but don't take my word for it i'm about
to introduce you to some close friends
who can even better draw this link
between the future of biology and the
future of creativity
[Music]
i think it's really exciting how biology
and creativity have combined
particularly in the area of
health and outcomes and
how do we help people with blindness how
do we help people who are paraplegic
where we can start to read the
electrical activity of their intended
movement and have a robot do that so so
they can gain
you know that that
activity again and have that that
power in their lives again i think that
is a classic and beautiful example of
the combination of biology and
creativity making our lives better every
single day butterflies use something
called structural color which involves
bending light to generate color instead
of using a bunch of pigment so it
definitely saves the butterflies a bunch
of energy and making that pigment but
now because of some observant and
innovative scientists it's saving us
energy too it's being used in screens
around the world to make them more
efficient at projecting color which
reduces the carbon footprint as some of
our most common electronics and how
about the creativity of using mrna which
is pretty much just biological text
messages to give our bodies a heads up
that they need to recognize dangerous
viruses it's the technology being used
in some of our our most innovative
vaccines right now
[Music]
i think it's going to be even more
important to have the widest
range of skill sets that you could have
so
less specialization more
a jack of all trades including
design
design thinking design work uh together
with with that programming experience
and
so that you can jump into the new
technological advances that are being
made every day you know we're going to
be so much more
in virtual reality can you not just use
it but can you program it i think the
most important ones will be
curiosity and keen-eyed observational
skills
see curiosity fuels the question why
which is an essential part of every
innovation and keen observational skills
allow us not to waste our efforts
reinventing the wheel life has already
solved so many of the toughest problems
that the world can possibly throw in it
so why not figure out how biology has
overcome an obstacle and adapt or
improve on that
i'd encourage every single one of you to
spend some time immersed in a different
culture or maybe even spend some time
working in a totally different part of
the world from where you grew up
now
it doesn't have to be quite that drastic
it could be as simple as
investing in relationships with people
from other parts of the world
and while you're at it i'd encourage you
to learn a different language both both
both of those experiences i think will
stretch your mind in ways that help
you consider other possibilities
students can expand their creative and
scientific skill sets by thinking beyond
the classroom and beyond the textbook
using that information from classroom
and from the textbook and from other
formal information sources and expanding
that to learn more about both today's
world and the world that you imagine for
the future that involves using those
skills such as communication and problem
solving and critical thinking
to wonder not just about what is already
known but to wonder about what is not
yet known which involves using
creativity to think
and to wonder and it also means
communicating with other people to see
how they want to shape the world as well
[Music]
we have the opportunity to work together
with a variety of different voices
colleagues from all over the world
who have different um
strengths that they bring different
perspectives that they bring about life
and about how the world operates and
only when we bring those voices together
where we have a more complete picture
about how the living world works
so
in order to uh
really solve the problems of the future
we're going to need to work together as
a global community problems are not
solved in isolation they're solved in
collaborative groups with other people
and they're solved to be realistic so
you have to consider not just your own
discipline or your own science but also
some economics and ethics and other
things that relate to the real world to
help you reach a real world but sensible
solution so it requires combining all
those different ways of thinking being
communicative and problem solving and
working with other people so that you
can reach solutions that actually
benefit the world because some solutions
are going to be great on paper but in
practice they aren't really practical so
that's why using new ways of thinking to
solve problems is really important
as an example for me in my phd project i
um
even though my background has been in
biology the problem that i really that
really
captured my interest and that i wanted
to pursue uh involves
mechanics and physics
and so it required learning a lot of
some deep um
theories and ideas and physics that i
wouldn't have thought of before and now
i kind of approach it so change the way
that i approach biological problems now
i have this physics lens that i didn't
have before and that expands the
possibilities of experiments i can think
of or hypotheses i could have for how
something works
what are those biological
solutions that can be solved with
creativity
that would change the world and i always
go to
those health biological
changes
the cure for cancer
uh the cure for blindness
the cure for name
alzheimer's disease
for example the
modulation of our crops that would allow
us to feed the world everybody so
there's no starvation that is the goal
that all of our creativity uh kind of uh
taken together is headed towards i think
that's inspiring i think that is doable
and with all the tools that we've been
talking about technology storytelling
and
inspiration all that together is going
to get us there a creative approach to
biology can help solve the problems of
the future i mean
if you think about natural systems they
don't have any waste
they recycle everything
everything that goes into a natural
system is used completely
and there are a lot of areas in which we
can learn from that as people and the
systems that we create in design
so if we can design ways to more
efficiently use water recycle and reduce
the amount of waste we produce that's
going to be one of the most important
innovations of the future by providing
fresh and clean water to a growing
population for this world new
innovations that i think will help us
approach science creatively in the
future really involve data and such as
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and using data to help
humans make decisions collaboratively
with either other humans but also with
artificial intelligence there's so much
data that exists in the world collected
from scientific and engineering
observations
that we can take this information help
us make to help us make better decisions
in the future because it's going to be a
combination of people thinking but also
machines thinking and that can help us
make more powerful conclusions